for days the exact location of kremlin
critic alexey navani has been a secret
but we now know where he is and navalny
himself is describing it as a quote
real concentration camp this was posted
to his instagram account on monday
navalny or his team
said he was inside a notorious penal
colony
outside of moscow the photo of him in
the post is an old one
but navalny said his head had been
shaved he said inmates are under
constant surveillance and that a prison
guard wakes him
every hour at night navalny is serving
several years behind bars for violating
parole terms
while he was recovering in germany from
poisoning
world powers including germany have
demanded navalny's release
let's get an update on that situation
now from journalist theo matz who joins
us from moscow
tia what do we know about the penal
colony number two
well we'd heard from former inmates even
before mr navalny was
transferred there that this is a very
tough
institution there have been reports of
harsh conditions
uh psychological pressure on inmates
certain violence one former prisoner
even said that this was where the state
sent people
when they want to break them and then as
you say some more information
coming through from navalny's instagram
post yesterday this constant
surveillance
he compared it to a concentration camp
he also compared it to
george orwell's 1984 video cameras
everywhere so even though we haven't
seen inside the prison we don't have any
images of his cell we know that this is
a very difficult place to be
indeed speaking of a very difficult
place russia's penal camps are notorious
for brutal conditions torture
and even death so far navalny seems to
be
okay is he at risk though
he's afforded a certain protection by
his status he is
probably the world's most prominent
political prisoner at the moment
and as we've seen through this instagram
post he is able to get messages out
most likely from his lawyers he is able
unlike the vast majority of other
russian prisoners
to commun to communicate with the
outside world
so he is protected in some way but then
as you say he is coming
under psychological pressure he's being
woken up
every night um once an hour throughout
the night so it's certainly not that
he's getting
particularly special treatment or not
that he's being left alone
by these prison wardens well that
treatment of course is considered uh
torture by some and
how did supporters and the family of
navalny react
to this message
well we don't have any statement from
his family yet
supporters have been sharing it very
widely
on social media there's certainly the
the feeling that
any news is is not necessarily good news
but it's definitely
a relief because he's been out of
contact
for the last few days he was out of
contact before
during his jailing when he was being
transferred from one
institution to another and whenever that
happens there is a lot of anxiety about
where he is and if anything might have
happened to him
so the the reaction to this has it
certainly
calmed his supporters to a certain
extent just to know where he
is even if it is in an institution of
this kind
uh here today navalny was expected to
attend a hearing in a moscow court via
video link
uh at issue was his
lawyers um
accusation really that moscow is doing
too little to investigate navalny's
poisoning
what came out of this hearing
well the hearing's actually been
postponed until next week
it was a very brief court hearing his
lawyer was launching a complaint
launching an appeal
against the lack of investigation into
his poisoning
in siberia we actually didn't hear from
navalny at
all in the end we just heard from a
state prosecutor
who said that he didn't see any reason
for this
complaint to be upheld it's almost
certainly
not going to be upheld the authorities
aren't going to investigate
anything that they don't want to
investigate
so really navalny's team are just doing
what they can
to keep his case in the legal system
keep his case
in the news and keep attention focused
on his plight while he
is in this prison thank you very much
for that update theomath
you